he's JJ Watt the 3-time NFL Defensive
Player of the Year and also the recent
host is Saturday Night Live
good morning JJ how nervous were you on
Saturday night good morning Dan I am far
more nervous for this interview right
now no no that's not true walk me
through the week I was telling I told
this to Jimmy Fallon on Thursday and I
said it to everybody at SNL throughout
the week I wish everybody could go
through that to see and understand and
appreciate what happens at Saturday
Night Live and how they put on that show
every week I mean you get there on you
start on Monday and it's some
introductions and stuff like that but
you don't you don't pick the skits that
you're going to do for the show until
Wednesday night at like 9:00 or 10:00
p.m. so they don't start building any
sets any costumes anything until
basically Thursday morning and they get
all of that ready for Saturday night and
it is it is a wild process to watch it
is a wild process to experience it was
uh it was really cool to go through
because it's just it's so impressive
what they accomplished in such a short
amount of time what's the latest you
stayed up the longest day you had the
longest day by far was Friday so Friday
is a day that you do the pre tapes so we
shot we went to City field and we shot
in the morning we shot the Robbie sketch
the fake Rudy and then at night after
rehearsals all day we went back to Citi
Field and we shot the steak men the
skincare commercial and so I started
that day I woke up at probably 5:45 six
and I got back to my room at 3:15 in the
morning what was the script you read
where you go oh not oh but it was just I
after I read pizza place and the dog I
gave my mom a call because I knew this
is with my grandma
and they were all going to be with so
this was kind of funny so my family was
all down at Super Bowl because TJ was up
for Defensive Player of the Year and
they were gonna go to NFL honor so they
were all down there for that and they
were sitting at the Gatorade hotel
because we're all Gatorade athletes and
Gatorade put us up and Gatorade turned
their like board room downstairs into an
SNL watch party suite so as my whole
family all the Gatorade people my
parents and my grandma we're going to be
watching SNL and I knew this and so I'm
like rehearsing going through this and I
have the pizza place skit which is
basically I mean the 80s you know and
then we have a sex talk with my kid and
so I had to call my parents and be like
just listen if you see me come out with
a towel over my shoulder just Ngram out
of the bath and of course you don't get
any money as the pizza delivery guy it's
all about getting sex
it says favors that you get favors yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely and I never
bring back any cash and there's always
something wrong with the piece so yeah
that's great
okay so right before you're going out
there and let's say you go out at 11:30
11:35 eastern time and then yeah what's
that like those that five minutes four
minutes three minutes right before
you're ready to go out
um you go they take you through like to
all the back the back pathways to get
you back up behind the door to come out
and then you're standing behind that
door just listen to the band play and
watching you there's a little monitor
back there that you can watch the intro
on and I was there's two ladies that are
unbelievable that leads you through the
whole day so there's a woman named Donna
and she literally is responsible for
getting me from set to set to set and
changes and constant changes and
everything so it's an hour-and-a-half
show and I think I was in like nine
sketches or something like that so
that's nine wig changes costume changes
once was a full prosthetic face this
woman as soon as you finish a sketch
grabs her hand and is in a dead sprint
to the next changing location and she
told me the day before she said I don't
know if you're gonna be able to keep up
with me and I looked there and I was
like yeah sure Donna whatever the first
time we actually did it I was like both
I'm gonna keep be able to keep up with
Donna it was incredible talking to Jay
Jay wanted the Texans how was the
after-party
it was awesome it was it was awesome
it's been hands-down the latest I have
stayed up in many many years but just
having drinks and sitting down and
talking to Lorne Michaels and just going
over at all in the cast and had my
friends there my fiance there there was
it was such a cool moment to kind of be
able to come down off the high of the
show and just take it all in and have
some fun and let it loose you also
played The Bachelor I did I did and I
never I didn't watch The Bachelor I
haven't watched the bachelor also we I'm
on I'm on and read it at the table read
and I was like yeah I guess this is
funny and then the first time we did at
the dress rehearsal it got it went crazy
people laughed like crazy and I was like
oh I guess this is gonna go over well
and then we did it live and it went over
really well so Monday night this week my
fiance goes we should watch a bachelor
just to see how accurate it was
then you know that The Bachelor is a
three hour show hey you're in love now
you have to do those things we start
watching just for 10 minutes in by the
way the character was accurate this is
crazy was very accurate like my fiancee
she's never watched it before either and
she was honest about that and she after
10 minutes she goes oh I'm hooked I was
like oh no so now you know what I'm
doing next Monday Dan 20 more hours of
that guy did you watch the Super Bowl
we were actually flying back from New
York City for most of it so we got back
for like the sum of the second half but
no I didn't get to see the whole thing
what do you think I mean the chief did
it again they've had an incredible run
obviously we've come back and being able
to really put it all together while
being behind and had finding a way to
come back and make some incredible
things happen and they did it again and
I think it's very very impressive what
they did and they obviously deserve to
be champions have you looked at that
game that you guys had with the Chiefs
oh yeah
would you is there a moment where you
feel like it just slipped away or you
could feel like it was turning I mean it
was just it was just tough all around I
mean they played it really well and
obviously as the game when I all we
didn't play very well and so no I can't
say that there was like exactly one
baller but it was it's not fun to watch
I can tell you that much what's the
scouting report on the Holmes he's great
man he's just and he can do some
scouting report hey Paulie you've heard
let's clear this everyone AJ watch
scouting report on the Holmes he's great
okay now the guy can do a lot of
different things and I think one of the
most impressive things
so he has the obviously has incredible
arm strength and so what that does it
gives him the ability to do some
different things in the pocket so if he
gets in trouble if he feels pressure he
can drift out of the back of the pocket
even up to like 10 15 yards deep if he
wants to because he can still make every
throw because his arm is so strong so
four pass rushers and people trying to
put pressure on him you put pressure up
the middle or you come you went on a
pass rush move inside he's just going to
drift out the back of the pocket or
drift out to the side and he can still
make any throw we can throw at 50 yards
downfield he can fire one in right
across the middle or if you rush up the
field because you think he's going to
drift out the back of the pocket then he
just steps up in the lane and he can run
he can scramble you can make throws from
there so that's one thing that I think
he can do that not a lot of quarterbacks
can because of his arm strength is he
can drift so far back that he almost
makes the pass rush non-existent and
it's it's impressive and it's very
difficult and frustrating as a pass
rusher because you're a lot of guys are
going to rush to seven eight yards
because that's where the quarterback
sets up that's where it always is and
with him you have you your target is
always moving what are the offseason
plans I'm getting married this offseason
so that'll be that's on the list we got
the invitation ating yeah no I know you
guys thought I was I mean I was in New
York City Hall last week and I kept I
know you guys were in Miami so the man
cave was empty and I just kept waiting
for like the hey man if you ever need to
use it it's open and it's free the keys
under the mat yeah never got that so
let's implied I mean I I sent it out to
your brother oh no Derek like you
brought the other brother Derek I said
it I said you know yeah I said if he
needed a place to crash he could come to
the man cave here that's a must he
doesn't talk to me so that's not gonna
happen and I get it I get it so you know
if if you need somebody to there you
know maybe give a speech again I'm good
at speeches that I give a speech maybe
it the way
you let me know you know what I do I
feel like there this will do for you
free I will announce the wedding party
that's it that's all do oh I won't even
stay but that'd be great
I'd be great are you a rehearsed are you
rehearse speech giver or your paper
speech giver or no scripted all going
sorry and now one of the groomsman at
six for 250 say hello to TJ why what do
you think I still I'm sure I'm gonna
need the height and weight or you a
Beyonce what I'll do that
free of charge I won't even stay for the
wedding I'll just I you know I know
there'll be an open bar but I won't even
stay for that I'll just go in there and
it would be my gift to you I'll be the
public address announcer and then I'll
go I'll be great
yeah if Seaton could stop by so I could
smash another pie in his face
oh yeah you know what like it's like a
wedding cake wedding cake instead of
smashing it in your fiance's face you do
it for Seton you smash him I mean guys
this is shaping up to be a great wedding
I don't know how we haven't had this in
the works for years and Todd will be
creepy he'll hug all of the bridesmaids
yes time wait what happened yesterday we
were texting so I was trying to set up
get me on the show here and we were
texting and Todd said is there anything
you want us to promote on the show for
your anything plug and I said I know I
don't really have anything to plug just
my ravishingly good looks you know as a
joke and then all of a sudden
Todd texts back and goes no arguments
there my friend you are truly handsome
that's offsides on I got caught up in
the moment I was so excited
communicating without Flannery was
coming on and I I believe the exact
words were no argument here handsome
oh my god I'd like to apologize
obviously was a one-sided situation oh
hey thanks for joining us you did a
great job on SNL and obviously good luck
in the off season there thank you guys
you guys have a great day we'll see so
that's JJ Watt there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]